Film Courage: Just to follow-up on what we
were talking about previously.
There are two schools of thought, you have
people who say “You can’t be so precious
about the work.
You can’t hold it so tightly and be so paranoid”
(i.e., over-protective of your ideas/intellectual
property).
And then you have someone brilliant like Steve
Jobs who was incredibly secretive about ideas/upcoming
products, etc.
[From what we’ve read] you wouldn’t no
sometimes what was coming out from Apple or
there were rumors in Silicon Valley, whatever
and we [The General Public] wouldn’t know
until years later sometimes.
Which this [secretive] style obviously worked
out for him in many ways.
So it’s an interesting mix.
How do we go in the middle where we are not
too paranoid about our work being taken (too
precious).
I see some filmmakers who won’t even have
their trailer embeddable because they are
afraid for whatever (maybe they just didn’t
click the button) but to that level versus
someone that is an open book that is (unfortunately)
easily taken advantage of (and I’m not saying
this happened in your case).
Believing in the good in people (because you’re
good) but protecting yourself.
I think there is a fine line.
Gary W. Goldstein: Look there are two sides
to ever idea.
And one is knowing the time and the place.
A lot of filmmakers hold their cards so close
to their vest or their chest that it’s self-defeating.
A classic example, most studio executives
in the marketing department will tell you
that they are considered Satan by filmmakers.
Filmmakers will not share one iota of their
film, one frame of their film, until it’s
absolutely locked and loaded.
Which means that the marketing department
has precious little time to think about it,
be creative and come up with great concepts
and execute on them.
It’s a last minute eleventh-hour deal and
it almost always is.
Is that in the filmmaker’s best interest?
I suspect not.
I know that many, many years ago I did a picture
at Universal, with a young writer/director.
His first directing gig.
And together we went in with story boards
and I insisted that we have someone from every
department present or two people from every
department (whatever could show up).
We had 16 to 18 people in the room representing
every conceivable area of marketing.
We presented to them and said “Look we just
came to say hi.
We want to know what you do and we want you
to be aware of our little project because
it’s not the biggest on your lot.
We just want to share with you a little bit
about the genesis.
We want to share some storyboards.
By the way the storyboards suck!
And you guys are so much smarter.
It was just a way we could communicate to
you.
But most importantly (before we leave and
shut up and have some Q&A, what we really
want from you is your guidance telling us
why we are on location shooting, what do we
need to bring back?
What do you need to do your job better.
What kind of still images, what kind of b-roll?
What do we need to bring to you so you can
be the best?
“ They literally said to us “We’re veterans.
We’ve been here 15 years, 20 years, 25 years,
whatever!
We’ve never, ever had filmmakers conduct
this kind of a meeting.”
That was at Universal Pictures.
Wow!
Okay.
So there is clearly this kind of tradition
in the human race to hold very, very dear,
to keep very private what we consider our
IP [intellectual property], our baby.
And I think sometimes it serves us and sometimes
it’s self-defeating.
But I think you just have to be sober about
it and look at what other successful people
do and how do they do it.
The flip side of that is I never worry that
much about people stealing what I have.
I have this crazy idea that each of us is
gifted and special in a way that we would
do something that no one could steal any of
my ideas and do it the way I would do it.
Let them do their version of it.
So I can write a book or I can produce a movie,
I can nurture a recording artist or whatever
those things are.
An idea is worth very, very little in Hollywood.
It’s the people and their ability to deliver
on an idea and birth out of nothing, that’s
what we do!
We birth out of thin air something very concrete,
very compelling (hopefully) that moves people
(happily or sadly).
I think it’s the doer (not the idea).
So I think theft is actually an interesting
concept in a world of IP.
And I don’t really take out an insurance
policy.
I don't really worry about it.
I don’t think about it.